are you ready for destiny - well
hopefully you're not too attached to any
of your high level gear I'm Tony this is
a GameSpot news update and for all the
latest from Bungie be sure to subscribe
it turns out destiny - or whatever it
ends up being called won't let you
import your level or gear but you can
port over your avatar bungees official
blog post reads sequels represent the
start of a new adventure for every
player this led us to a decision that
would enable us to serve both the game
and the players best interests destiny
one power possessions and ever verse
related items and currency will not
carry forward the destiny sequel is
slated to arrive this fall but before
that the first game will be receiving
one last big event called age of triumph
launching at the end of March in other
shooter news you can check out our
latest escape from tarkov
preview to get a look at the new scab
faction and for all the biggest game
news shooter or otherwise you're already
in the right place
[Music]
you
[Music]